morgen ist ja ein besonderer tag in der
pandemie geschichte da wird dieser
sogenannte evaluationsbericht
vorgestellt das heißt experten oder
regierung ausgewählte experten haben
sich die diversen massnahmen angeschaut
und geprüft welche viel gebracht haben
die lok downs die masken die
schulschließung was hat was gebracht und
was nicht
dieser bericht wird schon heftig
kritisiert bevor ihr überhaupt
irgendeiner gelesen hat herr lauterbach
scheint vor dieser evaluation angst zu
haben wie der teufel vor dem weihwasser
es gibt mittlerweile ja auch ein
versteck der heißt wir wollen masken
pflicht der es gibt eine in der
gesellschaft einen willen bei vielen gar
nicht so wenigen auf keinen fall aus
dieser pandemie irgendwie raus zu
gleiten
herr montgomery der ärztefunktionär ist
auch so ein fall und zwar das ist das
erstaunliche relativ unabhängig von der
lage der man sich befindet wie die lage
im herbst und winter sein wird kann
niemand wissen es ist unbekanntes
gelände wie die zukunft im allgemeinen
wie ist die lage heute die lage heute
bedeutet ist sieht so aus dass von einer
überlastung des gesundheitssystems unter
intensivstationen keine rede sein kann
ich glaube damit ersparen wenn ich
widersprechen und dass die idance
infektionszahlen nicht mehr die
bedeutung haben die sie zu beginn der
pandemie hatten weil wir es mit einem
in der regel in der regel milden verlauf
zu tun hat wir dürfen nicht zu viel
panik machen wir dürfen die leute nicht
so trennen also ich so möchte ich werd
gerade auf deutschlandtournee und wir
haben sehr strenge krone regeln und wir
müssen nun mal die masse der den ganzen
tag tragen was ich auch gerne mache also
ob es nur um macht und nicht ich würde
trotzdem eine maske tragen und ich werde
aber ganz schief von den leuten
angeguckt und dann gibt es wirklich zwei
seiten und die einzelteile für diese
maßnahmen und die anderen gegen und das
wird die ganzheitliche auch da wo ich
jetzt wohne in balingen sind die flip
wer denker und man merkt schon wie die
leute so so aggressiv untereinander die
bürger untereinander aber ich denke
schon dass ich viel natürlich mit der
presse aber auch mit der politik zu tun
weil die ich dann ist auch schon die
ganze zeit an und man hört halt wirklich
nur dieses eine thema oder corona jetzt
der krieg und weltkrieges gibt
eigentlich nur probleme und deswegen
möchte ich unbedingt in der
veranstaltungsbranche meine shows machen
damit ich die leute ein bisschen auf
andere gedanken und ringe und ich hoffe
dass ich das dann auch davon oktober
meinen eigenen shows machen weil ja die
leute sind müde und man sieht es ja auch
diese ganzen konzerte die jetzt alle
stattfinden die leute wollen raus die
wollen endlich aufhören diese ganzen
sorgen zu haben und wir haben einfach
gerade sehr viele probleme und ich hoffe
dass die politik da helfen kann
weil ich muss ehrlich zugeben ich
verstehe nicht so viel von politik und
deswegen gebe ich eigentlich auch wie
gesagt mit vertrauen meine stimme an die
politik und hoffe dass sie es besser
machen aber gerade läuft ein sehr viel
falsch und ja wir hoffen einfach dass
alles besser wird das corona test fiasko
muss aufgearbeitet werden die bürger
test sind ja ab ersten juli eigentlich
immer kosten bis zum ersten juni immer
kostenlos gewesen jetzt werden sie aber
kostenpflichtig außerdem ausnahmefall
der grund gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach sagte im zdf dass man sich
die tests nicht mehr leisten könne laut
lauterbach lagen die ausgaben teilweise
bei einer milliarde pro monat ich möchte
die leute gar nicht darüber debattieren
ob im test jetzt sinnvoll sind oder
waren
wie es weitergehen sollte mir geht es um
das mangelnde unternehmertum der politik
die milliarde pro monat kommt auch
zusammen weil missbrauch mit unserem
steuergeld betrieben wurde jeder konnte
ein testcenter gründen es war nicht nur
ärzte oder apotheker geführt hat jeder
ein testzentrum aufgemacht und die
anzahl der angeblich durchgeführten
tests konnten am anfang per strichliste
notiert werden das hat uns ja auch ein
apotheker vor wenigen tagen erzählt ohne
personalien das ist kein scherz
ermittler gehen von einem schaden durch
erfundene test von mehr als einer
milliarde euro aus kontrollen der
privaten test betriebe waren anfangs von
der regierung nicht vorgesehen das
änderte sich erst als wdr ndr und sz
über den fall mehdi kaan berichteten der
test am betreiber aus bochum hat
gestanden erfundene test abgerechnet zu
haben der schaden soll allein in diesem
fall 25 millionen euro betragen auch der
für die tests der zweite preis war vor
allem am anfang meiner meinung nach zu
hoch der bund zahlte den betreibern von
testzentren 11 eur 50 protest drei euro
fünfzig pauschale für den test selbst
und acht euro für weitere kosten die
anfallen auch der apothekerverband
nordrhein geht von preisen um die 20
euro aus wenn lauterbach also sagt wir
können uns die kostenlosen test nicht
mehr leisten muss ja nicht vor allem
sagen wir haben einen wahnsinnig
schlechten job gemacht kann er halt nur
1 nochmal grundsätzlich sagen das ist ja
ein gutes jahr her und es sollte halt
natürlich über über nacht mehr oder
weniger eine test infrastruktur
entstehen kostenlose tests aus laos
novelle heraus sollte uns das führen und
dinge die schnell ändern sie haben
müssen sich entscheiden soll es perfekt
sein oder dort schnell gehen da kann man
natürlich im studio ein jahr später
sagen das hätte anders und so ist alles
okay akzeptiere ich auch aber es sollte
halt ziemlich schnell gehen und es
sollte flächendeckend seien selbst in
meinem heimatdorf im münsterland bei
meinen eltern 3700 einwohner gab es der
teststationen
und viele deutsche haben dadurch schon
die erfahrung gemacht dass das
eigentlich schon angenehm einfach war
diesen test zu machen
und wenn sie jetzt über die kosten reden
ich meine der dritte test das personal
die textstelle das kostet halt auch und
so war sehr klar gesagt wenn ihr das
irgendwie halbiert könnte es gleich ganz
vergessen damit es gar keine anbieten
also die frage wie viel wenn du mir
sagen 80 millionen deutsche ein test
können wir streiten ob 12 oder 15 euro
wenn jeder wenn jeder nur einmal die
woche einen test macht statistisch und
viele haben in den quellen auf 2.345
manche tägliche test gemacht was alles
möglich war und ok dann kommen halt
diese summen die hoch sind aber im
zweifel zum lockdown und den kosten
eines lockt bei uns dann immer doch noch
mal anders dann kommen diese summen
zusammen mehr die ampel hat ein
wackelkontakt die ist eigentlich schon
ziemlich runter gerockt also ich habe im
dezember als die neue regierung sich
gebildet hat nach den koalitions warnung
gedacht war das waren schon
beeindruckende koalitionsverhandlungen
das war wenig öffentlicher streit sollen
und dachte jetzt wird richtig schwer
wahrscheinlich für so eine opposition
wenn die so reagieren wie sie
koalitionsverhandlungen geführt haben
und jetzt war ja schon im januar damit
vorbei das thema verpflichtende im
vorjahr ist wie man es so im pflicht
steht legal jetzt inhaltlich aber dass
ein kanzler sagt ich bin für eine
impfpflicht und was soll man
gruppenanträge so als wenn helmut kohl
den europäer gruppenantrag eingeführt
hatte also darf ich ja schon mit an dass
die koalition nicht in der lage war an
der stelle einheitlich aufzutreten und
es hat sich halt bis heute fortgesetzt
ich meine dass wir jetzt diese woche
erlebt haben rund und dem verbrenner
motor wo noch im bis in die abstimmung
in brüssel hinein das war nicht nur
peinlich in deutschland das war peinlich
in der ganzen europäischen union per
twitter die bundesregierung ihre
unterschiedlichen positionen
ausgetauscht
es wird jede woche was angekündigt um
die bürger zu entlasten was hohe
energiepreise angeht aber jeder machten
eigenen und anderen vorschlag
entschieden wird aber nicht zu wir sind
irgendwie nach acht monaten dieser neuen
regierung die eigentlich gut gestartet
war mit koalitionsverhandlungen
schon so weit bis hin zum twitter streit
wie wir in schlechtesten groko großen
koalition ihren seiten nicht gewesen
sind also dass im umgang miteinander und
dass man das in so einer krise in der
zeit wo wir zumindest mal das risiko
haben dass wenn zum beispiel gas nicht
mehr ausreichend kommt etwa für die
industrie wo wir in arbeitslosigkeit
hineingehen möglicherweise in
rezessionen in kurzarbeit in der zeit wo
es mehr denn je darauf ankommt dass
handlungsfähigkeit da ist das
entschieden wird da sind wir wieder auch
manchmal passt schnell entschieden wird
wenn es darauf ankommt hat diese
koalition hat diese ampel in ziemlichen
wackelkontakten und das ist nicht gut
also nur als beispiel zum thema manchmal
muss man schnell entscheiden sie und
ihre union wollten im märz ein
einseitiges gas-embargo wie in russland
stücke hängen das können wir bei twitter
sind anders mit ausreden soja und da
muss man schon heute für einen fehler
der einfach so das ist ein bisschen
anders schon so wie sich eben versucht
haben aus dem koma management
rauszureden am ende des tages muss man
die themen dann auch so bearbeiten dass
es funktioniert und der weg den sie im
märz vorgeschlagen hätten wären
massenarbeitslosigkeit gewesen wären
wirtschaftseinbruch in 67 prozent
gewesen haben diesen elmau zirkus kabel
zum zweiten mal bereits und was davon im
fernsehen schaut der hin- und dachte das
ist ja wie früher im kommunismus die
leute treffen sind alle einer meinung
und wie üblich bei solchen
veranstaltungen wird das schluss
kommunika schon am anfang verfasst und
zwar nicht von den teilnehmern sondern
von der sogenannten sherpas in den
leuten zu arbeiten und das ganze ist
eine darstellung des umgetan lotto bafin
will der schecks gesagt dieses spektakel
166 millionen euro gekostet was eine
unglaubliche summe ist aber für andere
ist das peanuts wenn wir den chinesen
450 millionen euro entwicklungshilfe
schicken dann sind 160 millionen euro
wirklich nicht so viel das waren 18.000
polizisten unterwegs die leute in der
gegend haben sich beklagt weil das ganze
leben zum stillstand kam und ich habe es
so empfunden mit meiner hysterische
überempfindlichkeit wie eine
generalprobe für den polizeistaat aber
dass sie sich treffen miteinander reden
finde ich das sind nicht wirklich
wichtig weil in videokonferenzen kann
man das so nicht besprechen und wir
haben ja im fernsehen alle mitverfolgt
dieser so geschlendert sind und sich mal
unterhalten haben und so klappt schon
dass da auch ich sage ja party oder
jetzt nicht wirklich schon wichtig dass
die miteinander reden und ich finde es
auch als botschaft an russland nicht so
ganz unwichtig dass das der putin sieht
da kommt ja nicht dazwischen gut der die
sonne überall das ist natürlich schon
verstören und 8000 polizisten mussten
weit auch nicht sein aber ich bin auch
der meinung g7 muss einfach sein bin ich
total ihrer meinung einfach mal ein
bisschen auch wenn die brille von
johnson sind aber irgendwie war muss man
schon mal songs und ist vollkommen
ratlos seine eigene partei eis gingen
diese leute die es gibt nie schaffen ihr
eigenes geschäft zu führen weil europa
führen und übernehmen ein bruder ist
versager nicht ein hartes wort für alle
direkt nach wissen sie noch was andere
sagen auf einer das würde ja bedeuten
dass sie finden dass die regierung
geschäft jetzt keine außenpolitik mehr
zusammen machen sollten weil sie in
ihrem land in probleme haben das ist
eine schneidet ihn ein gerade in einer
first things first wissen sie und wenn
ich nicht imstande bin mein zimmer
aufzuräumen weil ich sie nicht
auffordern in ihrem haus ordnung zu
schaffen
probleme nicht gerade so groß dass man
als g7 zusammenrücken muss und
vielleicht auch einfach mal sagen muss
so wenn wir nicht nein ich bin sehr viel
zusammenrücken und das nächste mal komme
ich mit ola von britta mit und wir
können zusammen
seit etwa zehn jahren seit 2010
eigene energieerzeugung
abgestellt haben zunächst mal die
kernkraft dann wir hatten die sicherheit
von kernkraftwerke der welt
dann haben wir die kohle sozusagen
aufgegeben und haben gedacht wir könnten
das anderen besondere und brinkmann und
in wirklichkeit man uns aber nicht die
wahrheit erzählt denn in wirklichkeit
ist in der gleichen zeit natürlich der
erdgasimporte immer stärker nach
deutschland aus russland forciert worden
weil das weiß jedes kind aber die
bundesregierung hat uns das nicht allen
erzählt dass so ein windkraftwerk ich
war ja mal selber windkraft unternehmer
ich habe so viele dinge hergestellt
steht eben öfter als es ist rät das ist
leider so 20 prozent des jahres
vertrages
eines jahres also 8700 monaten hatten ja
also ungefähr 2000 stunden dreht das
vollers und bei der sonne ist das noch
viel schlimmer die solaranlagen haben
1000 stunden und nachts wissen haben die
scheint die sonne nicht also braucht man
natürlich immer dann wenn erneuerbare
energien die fluktuieren sind ein backup
wieder batterien speichern oder weil es
noch nicht haben gaskraftwerke oder
kohlekraftwerke die atomkraft gibt es
nur dann nicht mehr wenn sie die augen
schließen warum genau so genau so wie es
in china jetzt demnächst nochmal 250
kohlekraftwerke bauen wird baut die
ganze welt atomkraftwerke nur
deutschland er jagt seine preise in die
höhe und sagt wir wollen darüber nicht
sprechen das ist ein kleines kind dass
die augen zumacht und sagt ich bin nicht
reagiert das heißt wenn wir nein sie
wollen ja ernsthaft über die energie
krise reden dann müssen wie helle wir
hatten natürlich die noch zur verfügung
haben wenn wir jetzt über den winter den
nächsten winter kommen wollen nützt es
mir nichts zu sagen natürlich bin ich
für neue kernkraftwerke die sind leider
abgestellt worden in den letzten zehn
jahren in der regierung merkel und
deswegen muss man eigentlich sagen dann
wenigstens das was wir noch haben
vielleicht sogar noch die drei die im
letzten jahr stillgelegt worden sind
reaktivieren und dann endlich auch neue
technologien der kernenergie
entwickeln meine meinung ist eben keine
angst vor klartext das hat eben einen
besonderen grund weil ich nämlich bei
sky gefeuert worden bin damals weil ich
zwei äußerungen getätigt habe die auf
twitter zunächst einmal sehr negativ
beurteilt wurden und dann aus meiner
sicht hat dann der konzern sky viel zu
vorschnell gehandelt und hat mich damals
rausgeworfen und zwar weil wir ja nicht
jeder genau weiß welche sprüche das
waren ich habe einmal zu sophia thomalla
bezug genommen die hatte einen freund
loris karius der bei union berlin im tor
stand der stand ich im tor sondern saß
auf der bank und ich hab dann in den
kommentare sagt naja für eine kuschel
nacht mit sophia thomalla würde mich
auch auf die bank setzen da hatte ich
einen sexismus shitstorm ohne ende und
damals wollte mich schon raus werfen
aber eben auch das finde ich daneben
bitter dass ein so großer konzern so
sich von twitter orientieren lässt und
dadurch schon gehandelt hat oder haben
sie sich damals gesagt naja wenn doch
ein spruch von ihm kommt von dem diamond
dann schmeißt man wirklich raus und dann
war eine situation dass ein japaner aufs
tor geschossen hat und da habe ich dann
formuliert das wäre sein erster treffer
in deutschland gewesen den letzten hat
er im land der sozis erzielt weil wir
solche leute wie sie oder die anderer
meinung sind am ende brauchen wenn wir
nach vorne kommen wollen es ist ja nicht
so dass der mensch immer recht hat ganz
im gegenteil ja aber er denkt an
kompliment wichtig wer denker war ein
kompliment jetzt ist querdenker das
absolute no go das ist afg oder sonst
was ja
und wenn wir das nicht wieder
wertschätzen die die abweichende meinung
der kritik und aber auch mal den den
witz und der vor allen dingen der wird
also ich finde es ist was was wirklich
als erstes beerdigt worden ist das
eigentlich der humor in der debatte das
schöne ist dass ich wirklich einen sehr
großen zuspruch erhalten habe auch von
kommentatoren von anderen sender béla
réthy zdf tom bartels ard marcel reif
der geschätzte bild kollege und so
weiter und so fort von vielen leuten
wirklich unterstützen selbst eltern hat
sich dann in einem video für mich stark
gemacht hat gesagt wo sind wir denn
eigentlich hier warum was darf man
überhaupt noch in deutschland sagen wir
übertreiben einfach in deutschland ich
lebe zum großen teil in spanien und da
zum beispiel sagt man zu kindern sagt
man - das ist der männliche begriff man
sagt aber in spanien nicht - in mias um
kinder gab es
aber bei uns wird das eben übertrieben
aus meiner sicht und wir sollten einfach
mal wieder ein bisschen runterfahren